chris what's up buddy
hi rich uh you know
you know 30 years ago you know we saw
the soviet union collapse and we thought
mark's
a tiny bit sorry okay or just or just
pull the mic away but yeah we thought
marxism was dead but it never went away
on the college campuses i mean i i think
the only way we're going to save the
west is to just see a mass exodus from
the colleges i mean
and as from what i hear it's a problem
everywhere not just in america
well there
school is a big part of the problem and
and it just changes at different ages
like you know
even in the daycare centers where where
parents dump off their kids their kids
you know what you're supposed to give a
damn about between the ages of like
three and four and a half or two and
four and a half in some cases in some
cases it's like year and a half old
toddlers are getting dropped off at
daycare centers because parents don't
have the capacity to raise their own
children and then they put them in an
elementary school system which goes into
a public high school system which
teaches them all the same woke nonsense
not a lot of life skills um
the main skills that that that guys need
to learn because i know a lot of my
audiences guys you know specifically is
how to make bank what women respond
favorably to you know how to be
masculine like you know the standard big
stuff like
on a bounce of probabilities there was a
course that i took one time
um
what was it on it was on like stats or
it was wasn't even on stats it was on
like
you know if you were on a a tt you know
like a ttc bus downtown and you were in
the third car from the front
what would the percentage of people on
the bus be that were
straight gay trans black white yellow
and gay trans and and and gay black and
all it's like really like this is what
we're trying to figure out like this is
a skill that i'm gonna you know use in
my lifetime and this was when i was in
school and then you go to university and
here's the worst part i've got a lot of
friends that have put their kids through
university i know a guy specifically
that put two daughters through
university and they came out hating him
they came out hating men one of them um
became a journalist and gave a talk he
paid for the entire university program
she gave a talk to a big campus
of academics and spent the entire time
praising mom and on dad
he was like what the hell happened to my
kids
oh i believe it yeah okay so
is it a problem yeah what is the
solution to that really guys like
you're not gonna save the world by
hoping that the school system changes
you can probably save your own kids and
then release them on the world that
exists when it exists by homeschooling
them
that's my view anyway well you know rich
we also have an issue you know my
grandfather walked two miles to school
each way as a first grader
uphill we are we are so coddling kids
now and we're not letting them take
risks in the name of
you know safety i mean
you know i can remember hi i can
remember high diving boards kids don't
have high diving boards at public pools
anymore and
all this other things all the details
yeah
yeah it's it's just nuts i mean
i i would you know tell any kid to watch
you know like a sitcom from the 50s or
the 60s and you can see how kids used to
live
you know it wasn't this super protected
existence that we have now and then we
wonder why they're so soft
yep
it is what it is all right chris i'll
let you go cuz i got a bunch of other
people when you get here too thanks man
so nate's got this question here could
having more individuals in school and
higher education be beneficial for young
men so
like one of the problems with all this
nate is you've you've got a school
system that
the problem is most guys are not men
anymore right
rolo says that they're they're treated
in the school system like defective
girls even when i was in the school
system
um i can pretty much agree that i was
schooled like a defective girl right if
you if you can't sit still there's
something wrong with you
right if you don't color within the
lines there's something wrong with you
if you don't get straight a's like all
the girls there's something wrong with
you right it can't possibly be the way
the system structure the way that it
teaches you know kids right they shove
them in these little boxes and
classrooms all day with fake lighting
and expect them to do well
so what do you think about a solution
all that jeff um i know generally um you
can hear me right loud and clear okay so
i know from my own personal experience i
did private school when i was younger
and then transferred into public school
now i'm doing university so i know from
my own experience i had a lot more of a
connection with my male professors and
just the environment they gave off and
sort of how they were teaching things
was more conducive to my and how i could
um excel in terms of my education so i
know not a lot of men go into education
they don't see a lot of money in it
generally so i'm not sure if that is
something that could be possible
there's a lot less men teaching children
today and i'll tell you what like the
men that were teaching kids were
teaching classes like shop like i
remember shop was one of the classes
that
disappeared after i left the school
system and they would teach you basic
skills like
how to use a drill how to use a band saw
how to
you know um i've got a a
cutting board i don't have it anymore i
gave it to my parents when i was a kid
but they still have the cutting board
that i made for them where i basically
put together these different pieces of
um wood
um in different colors and from
different sources and it's still
together to this day because that's what
craftsmanship was like they taught you
craftsmanship
they don't exist in the school system
anymore so again it brings me back to
you know the point of well what is the
population doing right like what are we
voting for and it's like you know we're
voting for policies that remove
things like masculinity and useful
skills like craftsmanship from the
school system so when they take the guys
out of those conventional roles like the
ones that are teaching you shop skills
men start to disappear automotive was
another
class that
one of the
high schools had that a friend of mine
transferred from our high school to
another high school when we were kids
because he wanted to you know work with
his hands we wanted to work on on cars
those don't exist anymore they don't
have shop in high schools anymore where
they teach boys how to i mean
i bet if you were to ask i mean if you
were to walk into a mall or some urban
you know center and ask 20 men do you
know how to change a tire i bet the vast
majority of them don't own a car have a
driver's license and have never and
would never know how to change a flat
tire
right but that's the state of things so
you know when i bring you guys back to
exhibit a it's like i'm i'm just saying
hey this is where we're at right now
right this is what society wants to vote
for is the empire of nothing yeah um
because i know personally even at my old
high school we did self-shop we also had
finances
which was done primarily by men so a lot
of it was just teaching about spending
as well as budgeting things out so
could it be possible to sort of work on
standardizing the school system better
so that we make sure that there are
things like that how do you do that how
do you change that when everybody votes
for policies that don't support that
because it possible to sort of
like
maybe do individual studies to see if
it's
like how viable it is for like students
in terms of their success out of um high
school or even vocational schools for
example because i know that
close to me there's a vocational school
which teaches mostly like practical
skills like electrician plumbing
automotive and all that stuff
so
like i think
so how do you get them to change that
nobody seems to want to change that i
mean like it's getting so bad in the
school system now that schools are now
firing teachers
only when they get caught
for trying to
indoctrinate children with things like
uh antifa and like radicalist you know
sort of ideas right like there was a
teacher i think was in california was it
yeah recently that got canned only
because he got caught doing it otherwise
he would have still been in the system
there was i know there was one in
california i think the other one was
also in california
they go in you know they go and protect
that ideology
it's like you know they'll just look oh
fine okay you know just look the other
way until a parent says something right
and then it takes a whole group of
parents you know to change that sort of
thing but that's just that one guy
right there's not a movement that i'm
seeing anyway like there's not a
decisive order of things where
things are changing now that being said
it's happening in other parts of the
world i don't know if you know this but
in china they've recently banned or
sorry they're they're limiting the
amount of time that kids can play video
games now
they've banned anything on tv that's
like classified you know essentially as
like
a feminine male sort of broadcasting
like boys like k-pop and stuff
like that
and i believe i saw something a few
months ago as well that mandated boys to
basically have masculinity training like
you know to learn how to develop a
strong masculine physique and you know
competency skills and stuff like that so
china's already won the last part about
china china has already won right like
we are we are allowing society to you
know spiral into this position and i
don't think personally that it's a good
use of time to fight it because nobody
seems to want to fight it it's it's a
better use of time to manage yourself
the people around you and control those
things and if you think you know
something like an exit or moving
somewhere else where you're going to be
treated better is a good idea consider
that as well you know that's always a
you know certain uh solution to the
problem too
all right cool man thanks nate see
you